are dangerous if Thai is starting
dangerous so it didn't change our
approach
changed their people I'd say and
that's what were you thinking about I
don't care he's old I pulled Bears
I don't respect no one until they come
and give me 40. I pride myself on you
know what I do is
you thanks for taking on any challenge
that's on the board
[Applause]
wow okay Dylan Brooks on uh talking
LeBron James oh my hand live my man oh
38 that's old yep at 28.
yeah I don't have no problem with that I
like to eat listen man Memphis made me
proud tonight they they went out there
on demand they competed that's as as a
player and a coach
all you can do is ask your players to
hey just compete save it all out there
yeah and they did that and um
I I was proud of them tonight because we
we all we all thought they were going to
lose tonight because we thought the
Lakers would be like hey man let's don't
come back to Memphis let's don't come
back to Memphis and they came out with
no Energy Zero Energy Kennedy talked
about it at halftime it came out with
zero energy they thought they had Lakers
across the front of their shirts no jaw
no Brandon Clark no uh Steve uh big
Steve and they like they came out there
and Memphis just competed how about your
man Xavier Tillman tonight with the 22
and 13 playoff career highs in both for
X-Men he had a great game he came in and
he stepped up I really haven't watched
him play a lot but he played with great
engine and you know like you know Chuck
has been saying this since I've been
there everybody that's a professional
can play a lot of times you get caught
up in the system and you don't play and
you don't get the Highlights but hey
they're down two or three guys this guy
stepped in he played he competed playing
hard and when you play hard this is the
result